foreign
[Music]
22 a show from spectator TV where we go
a little bit deeper into your story of
the day I'm Cindy Yu The Spectators
assistant editor
over the weekend there were incredible
scenes in Russia as Afghani pagosian
head of the Wagner mercenary group
launched almost a coup on the Kremlin
let's invited comparisons to the 1917
Bolshevik Revolution but it was over
within 24 hours pogosian is now
allegedly being exiled to Belarus
although no one has really seen him
since Saturday night and the U.S
Secretary of State Anthony blinken has
said that this will not be the final act
in this play
so what's going to be happening from
here and what do we make of the
weekend's events anyway joining me to
discuss is Professor Mark galiotti who's
a Russia and security analyst and a
contributor to The Spectator as well as
Svetlana morinets author of The
Spectators weekly Ukraine newsletter
so Mark and Svetlana welcome to the view
from 22. Mark to start with can you
update viewers on the situation as it is
on Monday well it's not situation in
that on one level Everything's changed
on one level not much
we've had the Wagner forces Stand Down
leave roster vondon and varonish head
back to Bases probably in the lugansk
region
himself has not so far at least popped
up in Minsk as we were told was going to
happen he left with his guys to
considerable Acclaim from roster Von Don
and from the point of view of the
Russian State media they're more or less
saying that's it everything is over and
quite symbolically they have the sort of
stories about sweet clean street
cleaners busy sort of sweeping the
streets in in rostov to Bringing
everything back to normal but so long as
pregocian is still somewhere out there
and we don't know what there is always a
kind of a wild card risk so in a way
we're all waiting to see what happens
next
and this morning we've also seen that
Sergey shoigu the Russian defense
secretary has also surfaced some people
had been saying over the weekend that
perhaps pagosian agreed to stand down if
shoigu his his enemy as it were uh was
fired so what do we make of that Mark
well the suggestion is that in fact this
is footage from an earlier trip possibly
Friday
um that shoigu did it it's worth noting
that nowadays one almost feels that
actually for these footages to be
credible
um almost like a terrorist Proof of Life
video they should be holding up a copy
of today's newspaper
the main point about that is not about
whether or not sugar did or did not go
to the front it's that by showing this
this is symbolic this is the Kremlin
basically saying that shoigu is still
our man no deals were struck
and in many ways actually I think pregn
has at least for the moment saved shoigu
his number one enemy precisely because I
think Putin is aware that at the moment
who anyway looks weak about the deal he
struck with precaution having denounced
him as a traitor he's then basically
said well we'll drop all the charges as
long as you go to Belarus
if he also actually abandoned his
defense minister even if he had good
other reasons to be doing so again that
would look like a concession to
pregocian so I think for the moment we
can assume that both shoigu and chief of
the general staff get acid more of a
safe and it's probably something that
for example Kiev would be relatively
happy about
let's talk about Kiev um presumably the
ukrainians would have wanted the
situation to last longer and nobody
quite thought that it would be over
quite so soon yes everybody was a bit
disappointed that
so-called Rebellion lasted less than 24
hours
and of course if Russian authorities
would be fighting with brihosh and it
would be beneficial for Ukraine so it
could continue with its
counter-offensive
but we have what we have and there are
rumors that prehortion will be sent to
Minsk with Wagner Fighters for actually
attacking cave
but Ukrainian commanders say that it
will be a suicide because for the last
more than a year of the full-scale War
uh part of Ukrainian troops were
building defensive lines in the cave
region in the Border where between
Ukraine and Belarus so it will be much
more difficult for them to try to attack
from Belarus again because Ukraine right
now is much more prepared that it was
one year ago and do we know anything
about how Ukraine has taken advantage of
the coup short as it was was there any
movement on the counter-offensive
there was in domestic region Ukrainian
Army has been advancing near Bachmann
like north of Bahamut south of Bahamut
and as far as I know they really took
like 16 square kilometers it is
still not a lot comparing like to the
success that the Ukrainian Army had last
year in Hearthstone and harki regions
but Russians are well prepared this time
so
also there were a lot of reports of our
Army using like Storm Shadow missiles
and artillery everything they can
foreshadowing the military Warehouse in
occupied the nice candle house can also
in part occupied part of the parietal
region and Ukrainian command talks that
it is only a preparation stage and it is
still not like the main stage of the
control fancy
mark what was pregosian thinking I mean
I am now starting to talk about this in
the past tense because it does look like
this at least episode is over for now
but what could he possibly have been
thinking I mean he's crew and
criticizing the Kremlin and the Russian
army for months now but to actually
think that he could carry out a coup or
does he not actually think that he could
go through with the whole thing I mean
what do you think he was planning on
yeah I I don't think for a minute that
this was an attempt to seize power not
least because you know when it came down
to it he had actually close to Moscow no
more than say 4 000 troops I I think
it's questionable whether he could have
got into most go let alone sees the city
and then and then what no I mean I think
more than anything else look we don't
know so the following is speculation but
I wouldn't be surprised if pregosian had
heard precisely that he was going to be
arrested or otherwise taken down he had
made after all a lot of enemies not just
defense minister shoigu and so he
decided to strike first and to strike
first not in a way to try and actually
sort of topple the government because
after all he's the beneficiary of this
government but rather to essentially try
and show his hands show his strength and
force the government to make concessions
and in that respect I think he must have
been hoping for two things that didn't
happen first was Mass defections from
the regular military as it was a lot of
soldiers were not willing to stop Wagner
but nor were they willing to join but
the second thing he was precisely hoping
that Putin would leave the door open to
negotiations when Putin made a very very
intemperate address describing what
pragosian was doing as a stab in the
back as treason and so forth then I
think it became clear to pragosian that
there was no sort of middle way there
was no way he was going to be able to
topple the government there was no way
he could simply walk away from this so
there had to be some kind of
negotiations so I I think it's really
you know a man who anyway we know has
relatively poor impulse control but also
found himself in a position in which you
know it was his neck and arguably I mean
on one level although he suffered a
serious blow Putin through one in the
immediate moment in that he defused this
challenge
but in some ways potentially pregosian
has won something too if he was about to
be arrested or otherwise taken down well
maybe in those circumstances better to
be a millionaire in Minsk than just
another convict in a Russian labor camp
but presumably the Target on his back
will now be much much larger than it was
before the weekend I mean as we've
talked about already he hasn't been seen
since Saturday night
um if he is seen in Belarus in Minsk I
would still if I were him I would still
very much watch my back
yes indeed I mean look we know that one
of the things that our absolute hot
button issues for Putin are those people
he considers traitors I mean after all
he was willing to risk his diplomatic
relationship with Britain in order to go
after lipinenka and scrupal so I don't
think he'd have a problem with with
seeing something done to pregosian but
on the other hand there probably will
need to be some kind of of period of
sort of letting things calm down if
prigoshin dies tomorrow it's precisely
the kind of thing that makes him in some
ways perversely for the fact that he is
a thuggish opportunist nonetheless a
martyr to the the ordinary regular
Russian soldiers dying for those fat
cats in the Kremlin
so I think they'll probably let it let
it lie for a while but absolutely I mean
I I would not be basically offering
precaution any life insurance anytime
soon yeah not taking any bottles of
water from strangers or having a not
having a taster for your meals um let's
talk about belarus's um rolling all of
this because it was lukashenko belarus's
leader who brokered this deal and you've
written on the weekend for spectators
coffee house about as to how the
Belarusian opposition leader is taking
advantage of this how do you see that um
countries role in all of this of course
lukashenko is trying to serve the Putin
that he still he still can be useful for
him and the sporting they want to
negotiate directly with prehortion so
location for him and at that time uh
Sultana she is there opposition leader
in Exile she was calling for Belarusian
Army like to rise against lukashenko his
origin even against Russia the same yes
some members of her position who
previously were in the command of the
Russian army they still have soldiers
there who believe in free Belarus free
Builders without Russia but it is
unlikely that there will be a revolution
or big protests as it happened in 2020
because currently like a big part of
Russian army is in Bala Russia so if
there is like to be any protest it will
be
stopped very fast
and and the Ukrainian Army is not seen
as a deploy that Belarus could be even
more involved in the war
no they are constantly monitoring the
situation in the border and for the last
days they have been updating that they
don't see any movement anything so
it's unlikely that will happen also I
would like to add that uh prehorsion has
been constantly talking that the war
against Ukraine cannot be won with the
current command that it's in Russia but
he never actually mentioned Putin he
always talk like about the Russian
defense minister or the commanders but
never about Putin but also the media
close to the Wagner group they have they
were publishing the ratings of
prehushing and Putin and like that was
like second after putting in Russia by
popularity and of course Russians such
sociology shouldn't be trusted but if
those numbers go into media that that
shows that prehorsing does have some
political Ambitions but after the
Rebellion that he tried to make I'm not
sure how for how long he will survive or
even if he could become a potential
leader in the future for Russia right
now it is much more difficult for him a
mark Everson as well that this episode
may be over but it's the beginning of
the end for Putin How do you see this
playing out in terms of
um the threat to his authority from this
point onwards
I mean I don't think there will be
lengthy repercussions directly from from
this okay we should wait and see if
pregosian agrees and whether he wants to
start making more trouble I imagine he
won't if nothing else because he doesn't
want to jeopardize his access to his
business Empire his money and such like
but instead what this really represents
is the first time we've actually had a
proper check on what is the mood of the
Russian security apparatus you know
there are basically three pillars to
Putin's system his own personal
legitimacy he's now the money that he
can throw at any problems that arise and
his control over the security apparatus
as the sort of final backstop well his
legitimacy is clearly declining not
least because of this catastrophic War
as a result of this war the money is
much less sort of available and
therefore the opportunity to buy your
way out of trouble is more limited
and as regards that final element the
control of the security apparatus I mean
as I said it was very very striking the
degree to which not just the regular
military but also the National Guard
forces and the National Guard are meant
to be the sort of the internal security
force that keeps control of the streets
when when push came to shove they
basically preferred to sit it out they
certainly didn't feel the kind of
loyalty to Putin that meant that they
interposed themselves to the fast-moving
Wagner columns it doesn't mean to say
that the entire military wouldn't have
fought if it was a foreign Invasion or
that in fact they're all ready to
support any kind of challenge at Putin
but it does mean that he can no longer
count on their support and I think this
will be crucial because what we're
seeing is a hollowing out of the state
it still looks impressive but in fact
it's it's much much less substantial
than it was before and then well what's
going to be the next Black Swan event
you know this was was unexpected and
this has been dealt with but at a cost
leaving the ratio being even weaker for
whatever the next Crisis and emerges and
the one thing we can say in politics is
there will always be a next Crisis
whatever that may be and Mark I also
wanted to pick your brain on the Chinese
rowing all of this because China has
been Russia's biggest Ally throughout
the war um even though just through not
opposing the Russian invasion
um over the weekend the Chinese side
have come out to say that this is an
internal Russian matter which is
something that they say for things
happening within their own borders as
well but I was curious that that wasn't
that statement didn't come out until
after the coup had been stopped and
other commentary act within China have
said that this has been damaging for the
Russia for Putin's Authority so if China
starts to doubt Putin's Authority you
know I would be very worried if I were
him right now
look the bottom line about China's role
is they've never really been allies of
Putin so much as they have seen
advantage in certain sort of common
positions and they've been perfectly
happy to support Putin rhetorically but
at the same time president XI read Putin
the riot act about the nuclear taboo and
not being sort of so foolish as to use
tactical nuclear weapons had no qualms
with doing that we have seen a
willingness to send dual news
Technologies particularly through third
parties or Import exporters in Central
Asia and turkey and the like but we
haven't seen a willingness to do
anything that really would Court
sanctions like sending actual military
kit and the Chinese banking system is
very much trying to disentangle itself
from from the Russian one so you know
these are not the signs of a
full-throated Ally at the best of times
it's more than I think what this means
is precisely that Putin is an even
weaker position in terms of his
negotiations with the Chinese he was
already in a pretty weak one but given
that it may well be that the Chinese
will end up emerging as the main Brokers
of any kind of Peace whenever that
actually happens because tough medicine
is something that Putin is more likely
to be able to swallow if it's presented
by Beijing than if it looks as if it's
being imposed by the West well in those
circumstances again the Chinese will
have all the fewer reasons to spend any
political capital on on Russia and on
Putin and we'll just be looking at what
their own interests are so this will
certainly have done put in no good but
again I don't think it's going to lead
to a specific change in Chinese policy
because in some ways it's quite handy
for them to have Russia chewing away at
the west from their point of view if
Russia wins it leaves the West in likely
disarray and if Russia loses well
frankly the country will just spiral
closer into China's orbit there's a
degree to which they don't really have
to care quite how this goes very
interesting and so Atlanta just to
finish up then where does all this leave
the Wagner group and by extension the
war effort because the Wagner group have
been one of the you know most successful
parts of the Russian effort you would
say probably over the last year and a
half
um we've been talking about how it might
now be disbanded Putin's offered Wagner
soldiers who weren't involved on the
weekend Army contracts is this the end
for the Wagoner group and if so does
that mean Ukraine has a Fighting Chance
again
I wouldn't say that it is the end for
the Wagner group because a lot of its
Fighters
are currently like joining the regular
Russian army so some of them stay on
prehost inside some of them are taking
like put inside but of course it won't
be the same the seizure of Bahamut even
it wasn't complete but it was all thanks
to the Wagner group
and they were very cruel and prehushing
didn't Inspire the life of his soldiers
but anyway they were much more
successful and trained
and I would say even equipped uh then
the regular Russian army so we will see
how it goes right now
Ukraine doesn't give any predictions and
they just try to see how it goes and
just continue with the airplanes of the
counter offensive because
some expected that seeing what is
happening in Kremlin that prehortion is
approaching Moscow that some of the
Russian defense lines will be broken
some the soldiers will run away but that
didn't happen and I would say that
Croatia what is the difference now in
the Russian army than it was before that
currently now they have motivation to
fight and the soldiers who I spoke to
say that it's something changed they
they want to fight and they even when
Ukrainian Army is advancing they don't
want to be a prisoners of War they just
made suicide because probably they have
been told that if they surrender to
Ukrainian Army then they will be
tortured as Ukrainian prisoners of who
are tortured by the Russian army
so we will see how it goes and Mark what
do you think where does this leave the
bargaining group and the worth it
I think we've got it sort of unpick this
Wagner group in Russia and Ukraine then
I absolutely agree with I think it its
days are over it will be
picked apart as you know recruits are
sent to different units and such like
there's still going to be Wagner as they
were on the global stage though it's too
lucrative of a business if one looks at
what's happening in Africa where Wagner
is part of a kind of wider business
model shall you say in which it provides
authoritarian regime support services
along with political technologists to
rig elections and suspend send
propaganda on social media and such like
so whether it's precaution running it
towards or someone else we will still
still see I think Wagner on the global
stage in terms of what it means for the
actual War though it's worth mentioning
that Wagner was currently being held in
reserve really reconstituting itself
after the meat grinder of the bakmud war
that means that it was really going to
be used as a reinforcement element so it
was a small probably more closer to ten
thousand than the 25 000 pregoesian
claimed force that was ready in full
when the ukrainians punched through the
main defensive lines
its forces are being sent elsewhere that
does mean that one of the most effective
elements in the Russian military
is not going to be available when the
counter-offensive reaches that kind of
critical stage so in the short term at
least this is an advantage for Kiev
Mark galeotti and Svetlana morinets
thank you so much for joining the view
from 22.
[Music]